so the creative process you know this
from the first idea to the final product
is a long process it's super iterative
lots of refinement blood sweat tears and
years and we're not saying you're gonna
go out for a walk and come back with the
Sistine Chapel in your left hand right
so what frame of the creative process
did we focus on just this first part
just brainstorming coming up with a new
idea so we actually ran for studies with
a variety of people you were either
walking indoors or outdoors and we all
found the state all of these Studies on
the same conclusion I'm only going to
tell you about one of them today so one
of the tests we use for creativity was
alternate uses and this test you have
four minutes in your job is to come up
with as many other ways to use common
everyday objects as you can think of so
for example what else would you do with
a key other than to use it for opening
up a lock
clearly you could use it as a third eye
ball for a giraffe right maybe that's
sort of interesting kind of new but is
it creative so people came up with many
ideas as they could and we had to decide
is this creative or not
so the definition of creativity that a
lot of people go with is appropriate
novelty so for something to be
appropriate has to be realistic so
unfortunately you can't use a key as an
eyeball boo
but novel is the second thing is that
nobody had to have said it so for us
novelty it had to be appropriate first
and then for novelty nobody else in the
entire population that we surveyed could
have said it so you might think you
could use a key to scratch somebody's
car but if somebody else said that you
didn't get credit for it neither of you
did however only one person said this if
you were dying in a warmer
murder-mystery and you had to carve the
name of the murderer into the ground
with your dying words so one person said
this and it's a creative idea because
it's appropriate and it's novel so you
either did this test and came up with
ideas while you were seated or while you
were walking on a
treadmill they did the test twice with
different objects three groups the first
group sat first and then sat again for
the second test
the second group sat first and then did
the second test while walking on a
treadmill the third group and this is
interesting they walked on the treadmill
first and then they sat okay so the two
groups that sat together for the first
test they looked pretty similar to each
other and they averaged about 20
creative ideas per person the group that
was walking on the treadmill did almost
twice as well and they were just walking
on a treadmill in a windowless room so
remember they took the test twice the
people who sat twice for that second
test they didn't get any better practice
didn't help but these same people who
were sitting and then went on the
treadmill got a boost from walking
here's the interesting thing the people
who are walking on the treadmill still
had a residue effect of the walking and
they were still creative afterwards so
the implication of this is that you
should go for a walk before your next
big meeting and just start brainstorming
right away so we have five tips for you
that will help make this the best effect
possible so first you want to pick a
problem or a topic to brainstorm so this
is not the shower effect this is not
when you're in the shower and all of a
sudden a new idea pops out of the
shampoo bottle this is something you're
thinking about ahead of time and they're
intentionally thinking about
brainstorming a different perspective on
the walk secondly I get asked this a lot
is this okay while running well the
answer for me is that if I were running
the only new idea I would have would be
to stop running so but if running for
you is a comfortable pace good so it
turns out whatever physical activity is
not taking a lot of attention so just
walking at a comfortable pace is a good
choice also you want to come up with as
many ideas as you can so one key of
creativity is to not lock on that first
idea keep going keep coming up with new
ones and until you pick one or two to
pursue
you might worry that you don't want to
write them down because what if you will
forget them so the idea here is to speak
them everybody was speaking their new
ideas so you can put your headphones on
and record through your phone and then
just pretend you're having a creative
conversation right because the act of
writing your idea down is already a
filter you're gonna be like is this good
enough to write down and then you write
it down so just speak as much even as
many as you can and record them and
think about them later
and finally don't do this forever right
if you're on the walk and that idea is
not coming to you come back to it later
at another time so I think we're coming
up on a break right now so I have an
idea why don't you grab a leash and take
your thoughts for a walk
[Applause]